okay ten seconds until kickoff the chess
cube meltdown two-minute warzone rated
170 a yeah 107 players 1774 average
rating time handicapped here we go
give me that ticker let's go ticker
double the cue points Sicilian Sicilian
do I even have to say it
a variant oh just take a bishop if he's
free ah man was that a free bishop or
what oh man that's a free pun though
take the free pawns that might have just
resulted in my opponent resigning right
away I'm on edge too I want to just take
that let's throw this in the mix and I
have to remember this isn't one minute
game now I'm taking them I'm definitely
taking them and now let's do this you
capture with my [ __ ] ever
yeah after oh this is definitely an
adjustment for me yeah I have to be a
bit more accurate you can't you can't
just be going after everybody like that
anymore rub this no actually you know
what I just want to get rid of dark
square Bishop can we have that happen
please what's the story here
Queen takes pawn how do I want a castle
let's go over here it's a bit scary over
there
let's come over here I don't have much
time either let's take that oh I was
missed
I was missed
I'm not even sure if that move is doing
let me give a check here why did I give
it check their pawns just gonna push uh
I get the Queen I think I get the Queen
no matter what I think she's trapped now
24 seconds is not a lot of time though
not at all really putting my mouse to
the test
haha right to the test man this should
have been a lot smoother a lot smoother
let's go rook bu contributor contribute
okay I think everything is gonna be
tucked in nice and easy here but surely
this is not a fast game is it no quick
kills here no no don't don't pre move
that Capri move this I don't only take
point 1 are they gonna take the rook ok
now now it should be squeaky clean
squeaky clean pre moves the rest let's
see how good this mouse is let's see how
good he is this mouse of mine this old
mouse older and just with the higher
speed he's been training he's been on
the wheel I'm getting known a fried man
there's gonna be people who have on that
well there is a mouse slipping action
right there don't you dare try and steal
me me don't you dare
um don't be stalemate right
it's not gonna be stalemate check check
and this took an eternity whoa okay a
bunch of two's but I'm sure there's wow
actually I was expecting um I was
expecting okay this is somebody who has
it - I was expecting more people to have
more than two there okay so far we're
playing like world champions or the
candidate at least I was just this is a
line seen recently many times in the
World Chess Championship I just dropped
a pawn
okay let's try and make it work now oh
it's not working out here is it nope
I just dropped upon that Bishop out
there get out of there all right come on
Bishop pair you know you want to do some
damage you just know you want to do some
damage why is that Queen have to be a
pest get out of there get out
um the Queen right here is gonna be a
pain she gonna run away is she afraid
she might be afraid Bishop here Bishop
here that runs into sneaky tricks pretty
much need to follow up like that watch
out for G to keep in mind I am down a
pine there is no compensation here no
compensation disappear does not work
could take and then double check so I'm
what am I getting at it's put pressure
on this pond maybe whoa oh yeah
stay active and I don't really don't
know this is like and I'm not quite sure
what to do move okay wait now I'm gonna
take here giving up my light square
bishop I take here and then come back
now let's try this I'm fearful of having
the Queen's on the board with such light
squares light square weaknesses let's
watch over that a little bit and my
bishop is I need to get I need to
pinpoint that this bishop is gonna have
a wonderful home right there where's my
time by the way where'd my time go where
did it go
okay I need to get the pig where are the
pigs when you need them where are those
pigs I got to stop c-4 does they stop c4
the bishop move oh they just gave me
that pun can I get a pig right here
please let's go a pig is there it's
around the corner give a check
let's try this just to be annoying I'll
check
I have another check happening not so
fast I can't take that can't do that
there would have been a bishop move
where's my time they're wonderful
questions I have no answers to him no
answers to him
where are the checks oh I'm not feeling
too confident here time burners is what
it's all about
there's got to be me oh wait a second
rook takes Bishop very nice I'll just
take the rook can I go fast
oh man this mouse is terrible I I got to
win that one but I feel so hesitant with
moving my mouse man okay let's try this
a cilium and let me be more accurate
please if there's a free piece note to
self
take it take free pieces ah okay let's
go night there's a mouse slipper
let's get b5b for Bishop b7 in fact I
want to throw intermediate punch at that
efore pond let's see how they react okay
let's do this right now
get that d5 move in here boom boom why
didn't I take that and move sooner what
was wrong with taking that and move
sooner I'm at rook it's still scary
though still definitely scary here
somebody saying the check at a mouse you
are misinformed I got a mouse and not
have to take him back God take that
Mouse back I have to take that guy back
I tried and he was a very noisy Mouse
something I said earlier he would not
work well with my doing videos so I
think um after now this move my
opponents in rough shape
am I correct with that like I just take
here first yeah let's do that and then
push exploit that pin got in a crossfire
tricky crossfire oh okay couldn't take
with my pawn there
what's the knock out here let me just do
this
and
just back up here I guess whoa once
again once again once again just take my
clean
I'm gonna hang on to that pond now he's
past and he's fast thirty four ticks get
central clean you know you want to be
central actually she wants to be over
here to watch over h7 or rook c4 would
probably be good too I should break it
this pawn right here
let's roll here b4 might have to do this
first though
or a queen move one of those two these
are going down to the wire here
noisy noisy mice are not good they're
not good oh I better take that pond
before something really bad happens
before something really bad happens okay
now let's go at this one past pawn pawn
push coming up okay
where is the win they resigned back to
tournament where am I at
there I am I'm not highlighted but I'm
there I'm not highlighted but I am there
Carol Kahn let's try the fantasy fantasy
variation oh okay that's different
no let's do this probably gonna bring
the bishop out there yeah so let's do
this now it castled and I'll be gaining
a tempo on that night maybe yeah let's
do it now
and I'd like to get my knight here oh
maybe not let's go to the corner um what
I want my Knights would support this I
want to be able to push my F pawn but if
I have if this square is available for
my opponents Knights then that means it
gets to e4 so I want to stop that right
while I can
let's try this pressure on c5 whoa okay
I don't know about that will launch a
dark square bishop can I make that
happen I'm not moving very fast less
than a minute okay well actually I think
the rookie one move was pretty decent
because now I'm about my night on e is
protected I have this move and my queen
could play to f4 after the rut plays
there so mm-hmm just do that secure my
bishops position and now what is my
knight don't know my knight wants to be
on g5 take and then I'm on this oh I got
a piece making one now the Queen's
guarding that I want to get that bishop
I want to stop it from even seeing
anything
get out of there rook cannot deal with
you defend my knight that's not how to
defend it because there would be rook
takes Knight and the Queen's hitting
this so I think after rippy won get out
of there Queen get out
all right let's go here let's go here I
think this works out give it a shot
no I just dropped my queen oh no no no
I'm dead oh why did I move that night uh
and how did I preface that one I said I
think this one works out yeah it does it
works out good for my opponent Oh
everybody loves to see a queen dead uh
everybody except for me
Oh No oh no I'm on tilt I'm on tilt now
bad things are gonna happen now to me ha
ha it's working so good you know what I
was having visions of pigs on the
seventh my opponent says no you will
have no pigs on the seventh your queen
will definitely not be around to help
out with that what am I even doing here
oh is that a tough one to stomach oh man
it doesn't matter what position is
present on the board for the remainder
of this tournament I have that picture
ingrained in my mind right there oh man
okay I could get this pawn you could do
this don't you dare to start talking
like you're giving up don't you dare
don't you dare you could come back
you've done it before if you new to the
stream this is my um this is the time
where I start giving myself a self pep
talk oops hopes that will do some good
we'll see about that
in the meantime these pawns are coming
roaring at me here and
just dropped another one oh man
let's go night come on do some damage
you know you want to do some damage
let's go rook that's it
I gotta start playing more dynamic don't
play your queen here
whatever you do ah let's do this
not sure why these pieces are like so
appealing don't they
I'm not even sure what they're doing
about do that
52 tix uh-oh bad news happening on c3 if
this pawn pushes I don't move my queen
come on Knight be a pain would you just
be a pain in some way maybe they'll hang
their queen would they do that
move bishop so I can land a fork that's
my only chance maybe I should just take
this Knight
yeah he's got to go oh
get out of there look no I need that
Bishop around to watch over this
yupper alright let's play here
that night what a pain look at this pine
what a pain can I get that pine 32
seconds 34 seconds I can't even rattle
off the digits right grab on a okay now
I'm a little bit more comfortable just a
hair let's do this let's do that Bishop
here from there uh-oh could I win this
one I don't even want to look at where
I'm at
oh man am i down a lot
just take the pawn next time would you
take that a pawn okay now I could take
this are they gonna resign take that
offer me don't fall for me whatever you
do mean right here oh man I dropped that
Queen nobody should ever do that is
anybody watching when I did that oh man
let's go Queen these are not fast wins
at all either keep in mind I don't think
I've won a game yet with checkmate did I
there down back to tournament I don't
even want to look
42 and I have I'm not even on the charts
I'm not even on the charts what do I
have I have 18 and there's there's no
room for error in these tournaments
either mind you these are only 30-minute
tournaments you have to be flawless you
have to get a flawless victory I'm gonna
try this line oh no no no no let's get
my bishop here and then back up to g3
before it's too late now let me put
pressure on that night and take him out
if f6 is played it's Castle and hey did
I I mean I missed an opportunity for b4
there maybe hang on let's guard this e5
pawn I don't want to give up my bishop
just yeah but now I will
pac-man mode I'm on the queen are they
gonna miss it I know the feeling
definitely no feeling oh yes I do it's
not a good one
let's go night you were not doing
anything over there on b1 you're still
not doing a lot take with the pond I
want to get right here it's juicy it's a
juicy square get to the juicy squares
and E 5 is it probably do that no matter
what can i really be that confident
the queen is cooked cooked wings
variation I'm gonna take the bishop and
come back just want to get rid of that
ok I'm able to come back ok now the
Queen it's definitely pinned pinned
Queen oh oh man 1 2 3 rook moves 1 2 3
do I have it don't known to fry me back
to tournament 28 13th I'm just looking
to be to be in to be seen
can I get top 10 let's see come on let's
go oh they're not pairing me up this
happened in one of the last tournaments
I it was an air and that's exactly what
I needed
maybe I could use another air well I'll
air my way up to Victory Lane there Wow
I've a mountain to climb 72 nothing's
happening here eight games in eight
seven I could believe that
definitely there's only seven minutes
remaining seven minutes and change
they're not pairing me up here
let's go bit bit they're not pairing me
up with bit bit no they're not having
any of that okay
ah what do you do
you gotta sneak up and do homework on
striker
right here and see what a strikers
playing pot sirs plan strikers plan
chest network he's not playing air time
air time where we at where we at give me
a boost where the leaders I can't even
move
Oh another hear my game going yes it is
am i moving now I am d4 okay you could
do it
oh they're creepy-crawler variation or
what they're going uh a small pond
center I don't know about that but
something I do in the thunderhorse to
avoid exchanges the main reason cuz I'm
usually down material so okay oh all
right let's see if this capture occurs
first and I could take maybe get some
play on the F file a knight needs to go
and he's dead use a cooked piece right
there cook tonight oh oh the Queen let
me just take that piece and play here so
after the smoke has cleared I'm actually
threatening to grab here as well let's
do with the pond now I have F 600 tricks
on the rook I am on that real time on
this rook I'm on both rooks checks right
here checks
to give a check and then take I guess
are they gonna resign there's something
there's less than five minutes remaining
less than five for 54 53 52 I just want
a castle am i doing get this pun
watch me Mouse slip to be one as the
worst that would be the worst um
take right here and then do what let's
go rook contribute this is gonna be me
right this is me no matter what
no no no the bishop could block it's a
bath remove it's a mate though coming up
I was thinking Queen c6 if the Queen
goes here but these are the two squares
I want to cover after the Queen wills ah
man I'm getting Nona fried right here ah
man okay there's only gonna be time for
like one more I'm lucky forget about
confetti land I'm looking to just be
seen what I even beyond the charts I'm
clearly getting Nona fried right here
and I'm in 18th I need to get to 49 I
need to get there man I mean take sea
I mean this Queen take C what am I even
talking about Queen C six Queen takes
here they should probably just throw in
here if they really want to milk all the
time here o'clock o'clock milk her their
queen C six Queen takes F no no frying
action 46 yeah 13th place oh man come on
three minutes and change
you can't even let's go here I don't
even know if I'll even get this game in
no no no Oh what can you do what can you
do
pull bait and a fish that's what it
takes that's what it takes here pac-man
mode look up and then over how's this
working it's working oh hang on hang on
pac-man mode pac-man mode come on two
minutes 19 seconds what does that movie
even do oh okay oh I got me and one it
was a matin - threat right there darn it
let's try it again
that's giant now
jackaroo ski check check they resigned
back to tournament ten I'm in ten Oh
intent there's only a minute 52 though
oh this guy could Nona Nona fry his way
to an abort I would struggle to come up
with that one
all righty I have a nice Center what
does that mean what does that mean if
you don't know how to use it what does
it really mean you gotta push timely
pushes it's not a good one let's do that
that's a knock oh that's an awkward
Queen moved after me isn't it certainly
is certainly is all right now the knight
has to do something
whoa what is happening here that is a
free piece they can resign I'm on the
knight now I'm gonna take on the bishop
let's go H pawn contribute
let's go H pawn let's go H pawn
H file opened let's give a check the
King has to be scared now clearly
clearly he is scared isn't he they
should check on aged six actually
there's a juicy square can you see it
it's right here
let's give a check first and then
where is the main is that where crook
takes first no Queen takes here is more
precise isn't it more precise more
precise look at all the material to have
of course a precise oh they're gonna
resign no no no no no no no no wait a
second hang on 76 I'll take it I'll take
it no confetti I don't deserve any
confetti
oh man still having flashbacks what I
say I think this is all right I think
this is a good move Knight takes c6 uh
yeah who got it 110 that was a tight one
right there 110 Stryker and 108 95 90 to
90 86-83 and only then eighth plays you
don't even get a little ribbon nothing
no cubits don't have fun stuff ah man
what can you do